wie schätzen sie denn aktuell die
Erfolgschancen dieser Offensive ein
ja bevor ich damit beginne möchte ich
mich ganz kurz davor reden anschließen
möchte also betonen all die Dinge die
ich jetzt sehr technisch und militärisch
Ausdrücke darf man nicht vergessen sind
natürlich mit den Normen leitverbunden
und während wir hier reden vor allem
also auf beiden Seiten hunderte Soldaten
und werden getötet und tausende werden
verwundet das dürfen wir also bitte hier
nicht vergessen wenn wir uns die
erfolgschan der Offensive vor Augen
führen da muss man also klar sagen dass
der Krieg in verschiedenen Domänen
geführt wird wir haben natürlich jetzt
immer sehr das Land Domain im Blick also
das was sie sehen im Fernsehen die
panzere vor marschieren möglicherweise
auch das luftomen Hubschrauber kam
Hubschrauber und so weiter und so fort
und man muss klar sagen dass es so für
beide Konfliktparteien eines Vor und
Nachteile in den unterschiedlichen
Domänen gibt ja die Herausforderung für
die Ukraine ist dass sie also kaum
Luftstreitkräfte verfügbar hat es gibt
ja immer wieder spektakuläre Angriffe
auch in der Tiefe der von der großen
besetzten Gebiete auf z.B gefechtstände
oder auch Logistik Punkte aber es gibt
keine funktionierende unmittelbare Luft
da Unterstützung oder auch keine
funktionierende unmittelbare
entsprechend Unterstützung gegen
feindliche Kampfhubschraubern und
ähnliches und das macht es so schwierig
und wir haben gesehen also beim ersten
Angriff wo diese hohen Verluste erlitten
worden sind auch internationale
militärblocker sprechen von insgesamt 16
zerstörten amerikanischen
kampfschützenpanzern und manche sagen
vier bis sieben acht zerstörten Leopards
das ist auch durch Bilder dokumentiert
da kann man also sehr gut erkennen das
ist sehr schwierig ist quasi für die
Ukraine hier Raum zu gewinnen wir haben
also jetzt zur Zeit tatsächlich ja
gewisse Gelände Gewinne aber jetzt in
Relation zu der Distanz die also noch
vor Ihnen liegt sieht man natürlich dass
er hier diese Ortschaften im Besitz
genommen sind ein signifikantes Zeichen
sind aber mir ist nicht in dieser
Vorstoß nur wenige Kilometer bis jetzt
betragen hat also fünf sechs km hat man
hier bereits befreit es stehen aber noch
ca 100 km vor den ukrainischen Truppen
bis hoffen ja das ist das operative Ziel
um Strategie ist dann diese Teilung der
Russen tatsächlich zu erreichen man muss
jetzt abwarten es ist so dass der
Angreifer immer den Nachteil hat wenn
auf einen Verteidiger trifft der
vorbereitet ist dass der Verteidiger ihm
auch seine Kampfweise aufzwingen kann
eben durch diese z.B angelegten
Verteidigung Stellungen und da ist es
auch zu erwarten dass der Angreifer
Verluste hat so wie wir das gesehen
haben das Interessante ist dass die
Verluste sehr früh begonnen haben in
diesem gefechtsverposten dienen und das
einige Fähigkeiten der russischen Seite
wie zum Beispiel Einsatz von
Kampfhubschrauber an Kampfflugzeugen
aber auch das elektromagnetische Feld
dass man eigentlich so nicht erwartet
hat dann doch signifikant dazu
beigetragen haben den Ukraine
entsprechend schaden
die haben gerade schon angesprochen
Stichwort russische Gegenwehr wie ist
die denn ihre Einschätzung nach aktuell
aufgestellt
ja die Russen hatten jetzt dann mehrere
Monate knapp sechs Monate Zeit um sich
hier einzurichten es ist eine
Kombination zwischen dass sie einerseits
pioniert Kräften die also hier
qualifikationsanlagen angelegt haben in
einem sehr ausgeglichen System
untereinander gestapelt auch mehreren
tiefen und in mehreren Linien angelegt
wir haben es einerseits eine Kombination
aus Minenfeldern das Panzergräben aus
diesen drachenzähnen von denen man schon
gesprochen hat und so weiter und so fort
auf der anderen Seite ist es auch so
dass die Russen offensichtlich eine
bewegliche Verteidigung durchführen das
heißt sie haben also kleine Elemente
dieses Jahr rasch quasi von A nach B
sind können die z.B mit
panzerverlängerung von den Ukraine große
Probleme bereiten und Sie haben
natürlich die Komponente auch der
Luftwaffe die immer wieder gezielt zum
Einsatz kommt Luftwaffe bedeutet das
russische sich z.B Einsatz von
Kampfhubschraubern dir seine Distanz von
bis zu 8 km entsprechend sehr wirksame
Panzer für Raketen abfahren können und
das bereitet jetzt diese Probleme die
sich dann in diesen Bildern ausgedrückt
haben die wenn der letzten Tagen gesehen
haben da gehe ich einmal gleich direkt
rein diese verteidigungswelle
diese Anlagen die sie besprochen haben
das hat mein Kollege Carsten heckes mal
für uns zusammengefasst wie die
eigentlich aussehen
Bilder der ukrainischen Armee sie sollen
die Befreiung der Ortschaft macarivka in
der Region Donezk zeigen Kios Offensive
läuft über ihren Erfolg entscheidet auch
die russische Gegenwehr eine Analyse des
us-verteidigungsexperten Brady afric
zeigt von Russland errichtete
Verteidigungsanlagen in den vergangenen
Monaten wurden sie hauptsächlich an der
Front und um Stützpunkte herumgebaut
aber auch im nördlichen Teil der
völkerrechtswidrig annektierten
Halbinsel Krim sind auf
Satellitenaufnahmen einige Anlagen zu
sehen die Systeme bestehen dabei aus
mehreren Befestigungen und Hindernissen
das folgende Beispiel zeigt eine Anlage
zwischen saporisia und militopol
zu den russischen Verteidigungsanlage
gehören tiefe Gräben und Erdfälle vor
allem gegen Panzer auf frisch
gepflückten eckerböden erwarten Experten
außerdem Landminen davor und der hinter
kommt vorgefertigte Verteidigungslinien
sogenannte Drachenzähne das sind oftmals
höckerförmige sperren aus Beton die
Panzer stoppen sollen
ja Gräben erdwelle
Drachenzähne das klingt jetzt erstmal
sehr beeindruckend wir hatten auch
letztens den Militärexperten Markus Kolb
bei uns der sagte allerdings diese
Anlagen diese russischen Design gar
nicht so undurchdringbar man würde
nämlich auf der Karte des Verteidigungs
Experten Brady afric auch sehen dass die
gar nicht durchgängig sind und das hat
er ganz klar als Schwäche identifiziert
ich ähm Werft da mal kurz einen Blick
auf die Karte auf meinem Laptop damit
ihr das da draußen vielleicht ein
bisschen nachvollziehen können wovon wir
sprechen also alles was hier rot ist das
sind diese verteidigungswelle die wir
gerade gesehen haben und ihr seht auf
der Karte da sind zwar durchgängige
Reihen zu erkennen die sind aber immer
wieder gespickt mit Lücken und das hatte
damals der Herr Kolb angemerkt dass das
eigentlich schon zeigt dass diese
russische Abwehr diese russische
Verteidigung in seinen Augen recht
schwach ist
würden sie diese Einschätzung teilen
herausreißen
nun einer der wichtigsten Faktoren in
der Einsatzführung und auch in der
Taktik ist natürlich das Gelände das
heißt das Gelände stellt sich in der
Struktur unterschiedlich da wenn wir auf
die Karte blicken so haben wir den
scheinbaren Eindruck dass es hier sehr
flach ist was ich in der Wüste da stimmt
natürlich nicht das ist eine
Aneinanderreihung von unterschiedlichen
geländesstrukturen wir haben einen Wald
wir haben zum Beispiel einen Fluss seine
Kanal eine Höhe und eine tiefe wir haben
einen felsigen Bereich wir haben zum
Beispiel einen sehr abbaugängigen
Bereich und all diese Dinge und das hat
natürlich einen Einfluss auf die Art und
Weise wie pionierkräfte sperren anlegen
das heißt sie haben also im flachen
Gelände vergleichbares quasi mit der
bäuerlichen Landschaft mit Eckern haben
sie natürlich die Möglichkeit einen
Panzergraben zu ziehen oder Minenfeld zu
leben wenn also dann dieser Panzergraben
in einen künstlichen Kanal zu
Bewässerung übergeht müssen Sie nicht
extra einen Kanal entsprechend graben
sondern sie haben diesen Wasserkanal
wenn das ganze noch einen Fluss
anschließt haben sie das natürliche
Hindernis des Flusses dass er dann
passiert werden muss von den angreifen
auf einer Höhe bietet sich an z.B eine
Stellung zu beziehen für eine
panzerverlängerung für die voller Sperre
in der Tiefe also auf diesen
vorgenannten ackerfeldern zum Beispiel
überwacht das heißt man darf sich hier
nicht täuschen lassen von der möglichen
nicht durch Linien sondern diese Linien
sind natürlich abhängig vom Gelände
gezogen und die russische Seite hat
natürlich versucht gerade dort wo das
Gelände sich günstig darstellt für eine
mechanisierten Angriff das ist im sehr
offenen Gelände jene sperren zuerst
anzulegen und dann natürlich da wo es
ist nicht mehr von der Zeit der gegeben
ist andere Bereiche auszuspanne
wesentlichen ja das heißt ich würde sehr
vorsichtig sein mit dieser Aussage wobei
man natürlich klar sagen muss dass die
Kriegsgeschichte voller Beispiele ist wo
derart nicht aufgehalten haben
und zu diesem Thema Komplex haben wir
auch gleich eine Frage aus der Community
an sie da fragt Eduard kund auf YouTube
wo würden sie einen Durchbruch bzw
angriffsschwerpunkte Ukraine vermuten
bisher sieht man ja an mehreren Stellen
Angriffe und Gelände Gewinne aber ohne
volle Stärke
genau was wir erkennen können sind das
also circa vier Brigaden dieser Brigaden
der Offensive im Einsatz sind wir sehen
aber auch das unmittelbar vorher an der
Front eingesetzte Brigaden sich im
Angriff befinden was man natürlich sagen
kann ist dass aufgrund des eingesetzten
Gerätes man schon eine gewisse
schwergewichtsbildung erkennen kann und
natürlich das beste Gerät sollte dann im
Schwergewicht eingesetzt werden und das
war der Einsatz von diesen
leopardkampfpanzern aber auch von diesen
breite Kampf Schützenpanzern der Breite
kampfschützenband ist eigentlich das
beste gelieferte Gerät was das betrifft
da von Seiten des Westens besser als der
Marder z.B und auf jeden Fall besser als
diese minengeschützen Fahrzeuge die wir
auch schon im Einsatz gesehen haben das
heißt aufgrund dieses Geräts aber
aufgrund von Spezialgerät und das ist
auch wichtig denn um diese Sperren zu
überwinden braucht man zum Beispiel für
einen Minenfeld braucht man einen Minen
reinpanzer mit Rollen oder mit drei
Schlägeln man braucht man für den
Panzergraben einen brückenlegepanz als
Beispiel und hier wird gesehen dass
signifikant diese minenrollenbahn zu
eingesetzt worden sind bei diesen
Leopard und der Bradley Einheiten und
das war zum Beispiel die 47
konkrete sich eine Zahl zu nennen die im
Einsatz war daraus würde sich schließen
lassen dass der hauptansatz zur Zeit
momentan in Richtung dogmark das ist
nördlich von melittopol erzielt und das
Gelände ist auch dort relativ offen da
würde sich das auch anbieten aber das
heißt natürlich nicht dass die Ukraine
hier in diesem Plan festhalten müssen es
kann also sein dass man im Zentralraum
also aus der sonntagmark durchaus
Ergebnisse erzielt wie man das jetzt
sieht mit diesen Einnahmen von diesen
sieben Dörfern und dass man die zwei
Drittel die man noch in Reserve hat dann
umgruppiert und dann dort ansetzen hast
weil dort das Gelände vielleicht
günstiger ist oder dort sich die
russische schwächer erweisen dass sie
hängt natürlich jetzt ab von der
operativen Einsatzführung der Befehl ist
aber auch ukrainischer Seite
dieser Krieg ist ja auch gekennzeichnet
von hohen Verlusten auf beiden Seiten
und wenn man sich jetzt diese massiven
verteidigungswelle an guckt dann stellt
sich ja automatisch die Frage hat die
russische Armee eigentlich genug sollten
um all diese Verteidigungsanlagen zu
bewachen
und da ist es Dilemma folgendes und da
zitiere ich eine Aussage von dem
kommandierenden General der
US-Streitkräfte in Europa Generali der
vor kurzem gesagt hat dass die Russen
circa 350 bis 400.000 Mann im Einsatz
haben also das Doppelte von dem mit dem
sie einmarschiert sind es drängt sich
sogar der Verdacht auf dass die Kämpfe
im Park Mut vor allem dazu gedient haben
die Ukraine hier in diesen Raum
entsprechend zu beschäftigen um genug
Zeit für die Vorbereitungen zu treffen
auf die erwartende Offensive und diese
Stellungen die also hier angelegt sind
haben durch den Vorteil dass es möglich
machen geringere Kräfte aufgrund der
stellungsausbau entsprechend einsetzen
zu können und das sehen wir auch gerade
die Russen haben also in der stationären
Einsatzführung Vorteile ob es die
Einsatz der eigenen Artillerie ist der
Bereich der Elektro des elektronischen
Kampfes z.B oder auch die Luft nach
Unterstützung die ist offensichtlich in
den leichter macht aus den Stellungen
heraus diesen Abwehrkampf zu führen und
das hat vor allem am Beginn zu diesem
Verlusten auf ukrainischer Seite geführt
das muss jetzt nicht heißen dass diese
Stellungen die Ukraine aufhalten können
denn es geht ja nicht darum diese
Stellungen bereit davon zu durchbrechen
sondern man muss dann einigen günstigen
Stellen einen entsprechenden Durchbruch
erzielen und der Rest der Stellungen hat
sich dann eigentlich aus unnötiger
wissen weil man durch diese
durchbruchstelle rein schnell vorstoßen
kann
ja und da schließe ich gerade auch noch
eine Frage aus der Community an von
Christoph der fragt welche Waffen bzw
Fähigkeiten fehlen den Ukrainern die
jetzt schleunigst geliefert werden
müssen um wie sie gerade sagen so ein
Durchbruch an einer oder an einigen
Stellen leisten zu können
ja was ich natürlich hier ganz klar
aufdringt im Vergleiche der Kräfte auf
beiden Seiten ist der Umstand dass die
Ukraine offensichtlich der
Herausforderung hat dass sie nur
geringverfügbare Luftstreitkräfte hat es
gibt also zwar einige Luftfahrzeuge wie
zum Beispiel diese su24m die sehr
gezielt durch den Einsatz von britischen
Storm auch in der Tiefe wirken können
aber wir haben keine unmittelbar mitten
in der Luft und Unterstützung also
Kampfflugzeuge die für den unmittelbaren
Kampf vor sie vor Ort vorgesehen sind zu
Unterstützung zum Beispiel dieser
minenräume in Elemente oder
Kampfhubschrauber zum Beispiel ja beide
dienen auch dazu die gegnerischen
Kampfhubschrauber und kaum Flugzeuge auf
Distanz auf Abstand zu halten das war ja
das was an die Kinder nicht gelungen ist
das nächste sind natürlich auch Flieger
Systeme die mitfahren müssen um zu
verhindern dass russische
Kampfhubschrauber quasi diese Erfolge
noch einmal ziehen können und das sieht
man natürlich diese Defizite die sich
hier ergeben natürlich ja kann man sagen
man kann also das entsprechend durch
einen sehr straff geführten Ansatz und
schmale und tiefer wegmachen aber wenn
man jetzt in der Kriegsgeschichte ein
paar Beispiele sich vor Augen führt und
eines glaube ich kann nicht jeder sofort
und nachvollziehbar einordnen das ist
die alliierte Landung in der Normandie
1944 und da weiß man das in den Wochen
und Monaten davor gerade der Einsatz der
britischen amerikanischen Luftwaffe dazu
geführt hat dass die deutschen
Stellungen entsprechend vorbereitet
wurden dass die logistiknotenpunkte
angegriffen worden sind in der Tiefe und
da schlussendlich am tag der Landung ist
verhindert worden ist dass die Deutschen
Panzerdivisionen die Küste gekommen sind
und diese Komponente ist hier wesentlich
geringer ausgeprägt und wie sie also
schon auch gesehen haben in
englischsprachigen Medien wird auch
darauf hingewiesen dass die F16 hier
jetzt natürlich eine sehr günstige Rolle
gespielt haben
lassen wir uns vom Thema Luftwaffe noch
mal auf Panzer kommen sie haben das ganz
am Anfang schon mal angesprochen es
wurden ja Leopard und Bradley Panzer vor
ein paar Tagen von den Russen quasi
erbeutelt aus Moskau gab es da heute
diese Bilder die wir ja auch gleich
sehen werden wo die Aufnahmen entstanden
sind ist allerdings unklar jetzt fragt
man sich natürlich wie schwer wie denn
die Verluste dieser Panzer auf der
ukrainischen Seite
man kann die Bilder sehr klar einordnen
indem man also quasi die tatsächlichen
Aufnahmen vergleicht mit dem Gelände und
damit weiß man auch wo das passiert ist
nördlich von der dogmark bei
malerdruckmatschka dort war dieser
zweimalige Versuch des Vorstoßes wo also
diese Verluste litten waren sind viel
schwerer als der Verlust der
leopardkampfbahns und der Kampf war der
kampfschützenpanzer vom Typ Bradley
wirkt natürlich der Verlust quasi dieses
Spezial minenraumgerät das was auch hier
verloren worden ist zum Beispiel von den
sechs gelieferten Stückzahlen von einem
speziell mining Gerät das Finnland
wurden bereits drei möglicherweise vier
sogar zerstört aber das ist natürlich
die Herausforderung dass gerade diese
Spezialgerät benötigt wird und diese
Stellungen entsprechend zu überwinden
und das macht natürlich auch schwierig
wenn wir die Verluste in eine gesamt
Relation setzen also auch jetzt zum
Beispiel diese vier Brigaden und die
80er Jahren die also noch Interesse sind
das sind die Verluste noch immer relativ
gering sie sind nur überraschend hoch
bereits für den Beginn der Offensive
nämlich in der sogenannten
gefechtsverposten Diener das heißt noch
vorteiligen Hauptverteidigungslinie und
das ist das überraschende mit dem die
ukrainische Seite so sicherlich nicht
gerechnet hat
jetzt gab es in der Vergangenheit auch
schon den Fall dass Ukrainer auch im
Besitz von russischen Panzern gekommen
sind die sie auch für sich einsetzen
konnten wie ist denn das jetzt mit den
Russen und den Leopard und Bradley
Gefährten können die diese auch einfach
so einsetzen oder welchen Nutzen haben
die von diesen Geräten
das hat natürlich auch vor allem einen
Nutzen im sogenannten Informationsraum
es geht hier in diesem Krieg vor allem
um den Informationsraum und das
beeinflussen des anderen der Zielgruppe
des anderen der eigenen Bevölkerung und
das sind die Bilder natürlich von diesen
zerstörten leoparda Kampfpanzern ganz
wichtig für dieses russische narrativ
auch diesen Großen Vaterländischen Krieg
2.0 zu führen in den russischen sozialen
Netzwerken sieht man Bilder auf der
einen Seite einen zerstörten deutschen
tigerpanzer aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
auf der anderen Seite quasi diesen
zerstörten Leopard banza das ist
eigentlich das große bedeutungsvolle das
Fahrzeug selber ist natürlich
interessant für die russische Seite was
die Auswertung der Technik betrifft hier
kann man auch möglicherweise damit
rechnen dass er Komponenten davon
weitergegeben werden zum Beispiel im
Kino und sonst so aber dann nutzen
selber für die Armee der ist sehr gering
und zwar alleine aufgrund der Tatsache
dass man nicht die entsprechende
Munition verfügbar hat möglicherweise
die Munition die noch am Fahrzeug war
aber nicht um das Fahrzeug logistisch
über lange sich betreiben zu können und
deswegen Ersatzteile es werden alle
diese Komponenten die notwendig sind
dann wird vielleicht der Bilder schaffen
wo man diesen Kampfbahn sieht aber
tatsächlich ist er für die
Einsatzführung nicht geeignet
jetzt hat
Verteidigungsministeriums ja ab Juni
noch mal von 100 Panzern gesprochen die
in die Ukraine sollen wäre das denn ein
privater Ersatz würden jetzt schneller
kommen für diese Leoparden die sich die
Russen zu eigen gemacht haben
natürlich ist die Lieferung von weiteren
Bands eine wesentliche Unterstützung für
die ukrainische Seite die Problematik
ergibt sich nicht nur aus der Quantität
sondern auch aus der Qualität die ihr so
von Ihnen genannten Leopard 1
Kampfpanzer sind auf dem technischen
Stand wie zum Beispiel ein russischer
t62 also die Optiken haben ungefähr
dieselbe Wirkung zum Teil auch
schlechter das heißt es gibt also hier
keinen wirklich wesentlichen Vorteil im
Vergleich zu den Leopard 2 oder gerade
diesen Leopard 2 A6 den wir also hier
gesehen haben aber die Menge alleine
macht schon einen Unterschied wir sehen
das ja auch auf russische Seite die
Russen verwenden zum Teil Gerät aus den
50er und 60er Jahren zum Teil der
Sturmgeschütze dazu Unterstützung was
wir System aber hier ist es natürlich
auch die Masse die dann im wesentlichen
Unterschied macht der also dann aufgrund
dieser langen Front natürlich eingesetzt
werden kann sie dürfen nicht vergessen
wir reden hier von einer Frau die 1200
km lang ist das ist wie wenn sie in
Berlin ins Auto steigen bis nach London
fahren und hier wird es oft vergessen
durch den Blick auf die Karte wir
glauben das ist relativ eng und begrenzt
die Möglichkeit sind das sehr sehr große
Ausdehnungen unter verschwinden dann 100
Panzer gleich einmal im Gelände und das
sozusagen
sie sagen ja auch die aktuellen Kämpfe
dieser Offensive das sind Kämpfe die
sind sehr verlustreich für die Ukraine
können Sie mir und den Zuschauern und
Zuschauen einmal erklären wie sie zu
dieser Einschätzung kommen weil es gibt
ja aus diesem Krieg immer nur relativ
wenige Informationen es ist schwer die
zu verifizieren wir finden uns ja auch
wie sie gerade gesagt haben in einer Art
Informationskrieg
genau das ist der wesentliche Punkt und
hier muss man ganz klar sagen dass die
Bilder die wir jetzt bekommen natürlich
vor allem von der russischen Seite
geliefert werden denn die Russen
versuchen natürlich diese Erfolge
auszuschlachten für die eigene
Propaganda und auch quasi im Prinzip zur
Einschüchterung der Soldaten vor Ort wir
haben sehr sehr wenige Bilder von
ukrainischer Seite klar es gilt also
hier eine absolute Schweigepflicht um
also nicht der eigene Operationsführung
zu verraten aber die Bilder die man
natürlich von russischer Seite sehen
zeigen dass es auf Fahrzeuge ausgebrannt
sind das ist Minion Treffer gab und so
weiter und so fort das ist Treffer
gehabt sucht den Einsatz aussehen kann
Hubschrauber oder auch Panzer bei
Lenkwaffen und da muss man leider davon
ausgehen dass es auch nicht weniger
Soldaten gefallen sind es gibt auch
erste Videos auf russische Seite die
gefallene ukrainische Soldaten zeigen es
gibt aber auch Videos von der
ukrainischen Seite die Gefangene wo sie
sich Soldaten zeigen die sehen sie
natürlich nicht in der russischen
sozialen Netzwerk ist ganz klar aber das
Problem ist Offensive ist wenn Sie hier
mit geballter Wucht da Streitkräfte
aufeinander Ballen dann ist es leider
damit verbunden und hier schließt sich
der Geist zu dem was ich immer beginnt
gesagt hat dass er hier auch sehr viele
Leute sterben verwundert werden und das
natürlich mit sehr viel Leid verbunden
ist und das sehen wir natürlich jetzt
wir haben hier noch einige Fragen aus
der Community ich werfe da mal kurz
einen Blick drauf Jan soll fragt die
ersten Verteidigungslinien der Russen
wurden ja noch nicht erreicht das sind
unter anderem die Bilder die wir gerade
in den Beitrag gesehen haben mit welchen
Schwierigkeiten für die ukrainische
Armee rechnen Sie wenn wir vielleicht
noch mal ganz konkret auf diese
befestigungsanleitung gucken was ist da
schwierig
ja die Herausforderung ist und das muss
man eben verstehen dass hier die Ukraine
den sogenannten Kampf der verbundenen
Waffen anwenden müssen das heißt der
kampfmanns alleine der Leopard alleine
ist nicht die Wunderwaffe es müssen hier
verschiedene Systeme zum Zusammenwirken
gebracht werden wenn wir uns jetzt diese
russischen Verteidigungsstellungen
ansehen dann ist es zum Beispiel die
erste Herausforderung für die angreife
Ukraine durch Minenräumen Fahrzeuge eine
minengasse im Vorfeld der
hauptverteidigungsstellungen räumen zu
können durch diese minengasse und da
muss man leider sehr eng auch
beieinander fahren können dann die
Leopard oder Schützenpanzer vorstoßen
und ein brückenlegepanzer kann dann z.B
einen Panzergraben eine Brücke gelegen
eine schnellbrücke und dann drüber zu
fahren dann reicht es vielleicht ein
anderes Fahrzeug mit zu haben wie z.B
einen Bergepanzer vom Typ Büffel oder
wie sind der dann Drachenzähne zur Seite
schiebt wenn Sie den Hindernis
darstellen um weiter Vorfahren zu können
und man muss es aber parallel das ganze
begleiten durch den Einsatz von
atillerie die Nebel schießt und zum
Beispiel Panzer bei Lenkwaffen der
russischen Seite des fahren zu
verhindern man muss es begleiten doch
mitfahren damit eben der gegnerische
Kampfhubschrauber Computer russische
Kernhof 52 zum Beispiel nicht zum
Einsatz kommen kann und man muss das
auch noch begleiten für so viele Dinge
die wir vielleicht gar nicht zum Radar
haben wie zum Beispiel auch den
elektromagnetischen Bereich wo man
versucht durch Störung des Gegners
seines Funkverkehr Alarm zu legen damit
dass er ja keine Reserven reinholen kann
und diese Reserven aus der Tiefe die
muss man zum Beispiel mit
fernverlegbaren Minen auch tatsächlich
versuchen zu behindern also es gibt eine
Vielzahl von Komponenten denn das
Militär ist im Prinzip wie eine Uhr sie
kann nur exakt an die Zeit anzeigen wenn
all diese kleinen Segmente da der
Sekunde Zeiger der Minutenzeiger und all
diese Rechnung Zusammenwirken gebracht
und das ist die Herausforderung
und hier ist noch ein Zuschauer der noch
mal auf das guckt was sie gerade
angesprochen haben was sie gerade
angesprochen haben nämlich darauf wie
unglaublich lange diese Front ist ähm
hier fragt top Senf auf Youtube anhören
oberstreise nach hoffe die Ukraine
vernachlässigen nicht ihre anderen
Frontabschnitte wären die ihre Angriffe
hat die Ukraine genug Soldaten für alle
Fronten
da muss man also auch verstehen dass in
der sogenannten Vorbereitungsphase der
Offensive die Ukraine versucht hat die
Frauen sogar noch zu verlängern für die
russische Seite zum Beispiel durch diese
gezielten Angriffe im Raum Belgorod da
hat man also versucht russische Kräfte
dort in diesen Raum entsprechend
verlegen zu lassen und zu binden damit
die Front noch länger ist und damit es
um die Russen noch weniger Reserven zum
Einsatz haben wir sehen ja das ist die
Ukraine es geschafft hat tatsächlich
über die letzten Monate stabil entlang
der gesamten Front durchgehende
Verteidigungsstellungen auch anzulegen
und die Russen ist nicht geschafft haben
auch während der Winterzeit denken wir
zum Beispiel an den Jena hier selbst in
die Offensive zu gehen und einen
operativen Durchbruch zu ziehen im
Gegenteil man hat sich dann also
festgelegt auf diese Stellungen die man
bezogen hat ich denke dass zum Beispiel
durch die Sprengung des Darms und so
sieht es ja aus im Süden die Russen es
geschafft dann tatsächlich den Südraum
für die Einsatzführung vorerst
unbrauchbar zu machen dann darf er nicht
vergessen ein Teil der Front ist auch
der Fluss nebenra und es macht natürlich
für die Russen leicht an der sogenannten
südlichen Flanke Kräfte abzuziehen die
man jetzt im Norden einsetzen kann ich
denke die Ukraine hat in den letzten
Monaten gezeigt dass sie schon sehr in
der Lage ist dachte die Front und die
auch alle möglichen bestehenden Lücken
zu überwachen aber natürlich man
versucht jetzt natürlich Kräfte zusammen
zu ziehen und anzugreifen und es wäre
theoretisch denkbar dass er die Russen
an einer anderen Stelle angreifen es
gibt also einige Indizien z.B für Kämpfe
in kubianski gefunden aber gut aber ich
denke dass die Jugendliche Seite das in
der operativen einsatzführungen mit
berücksichtigt hat und auch dort lokale
Kräfte bereitgestellt hat
und zum Schluss habe ich noch eine Frage
für Sie die so ein bisschen in die
Zukunft guckt und hier fragt Kimmy Maro
auf Youtube wie lange wird die Offensive
andauern und was ist ihre Einschätzung
was eventuell bis September passieren
könnte
ist jetzt natürlich unter einem enormen
Erfolgsdruck sie dürfen nicht vergessen
in Kürze ist auch das
autoverwertungsminister Treffen in
Vilnius dort möchte man wenn geht dann
natürlich schon Ergebnisse zeigen um
sich auch da Unterstützung zu versichern
weil sie dann Auto starten für die
weitere Offensive Einsatzführung die
Herausforderung besteht jetzt darin was
in diesem Kräfte Ringen von beiden
Seiten die Oberhand zu behalten und
möglichst dann günstiger Stelle nicht
komplett bereit und der gesamten
Verteidigungslinie sondern günstiger
Stelle einen Durchbruch zu ziehen die
man dann mehreren kann mit zusätzlichen
Kräften und dann rasch vorzustoßen und
damit diese strategische Situation zu
schaffen zum Beispiel der Teilung der
russischen Kräfte in der Nord und in den
Südbereich und das kann natürlich ja
dauern das kann der Wochen dauern das
kann auch durch Pausen unterbrochen
werden das kann sich möglicherweise
einstellen und dann wieder fortsetzen
das ist das was wir auch aus dem
vergangenen Kriegen erkennen ich
vergleiche den diesen Krieg auch immer
wieder mit dem Ersten Weltkrieg
natürlich waren die Rahmenbedingungen
damals anders aber manche
Stimmungsbilder sind sehr ähnlich wie
z.B am 19
Sieg 1915 dann eher nicht darum dass
verstehen dass man nicht getan hat oder
1916 das Jahr der unterschiedlichen
offensiven die dann auch nicht das
Ergebnis gebracht haben momentan ist es
der Ziel der Ukraine zu zeigen dass man
in der Offensive kann das tut sie jetzt
gerade und man muss jetzt Geduld haben
und warten was die Ergebnisse in der
nächsten Wochen möglicherweise Monaten
auch tatsächlich sind
Herr Reisner vielen vielen Dank dass Sie
meine Fragen und die Fragen unserer
Zuschauer an ZuschauerInnen so ausgiebig
beantwortet haben
herzlichen